kosten wasser wir sind in
schwierigkeiten
einbrachte kenterten einem wintersturm
die besatzung stürzt ins eisige wasser
es war unbeschreiblich kalt höchstens
eine stunde bist du durch unterkühlung
bewusstlos wird das schiff hatte schon
einige stürme überstanden warum führte
dieser in die katastrophe
besser kann es nicht gewesen sein aber
was dann
die unfallermittler stehen vor einem
rätsel
und stoßen auf verblüffend ist
unfassbar diese tragödie hätte geschehen
dürfen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein stürmischer wintertag vor der küste
des us bundesstaates virginia
[Musik]
kapitän philipp kohl ist mit dem
massengutfrachter marin electric auf
eine hier kurzen fahrt die küste hinauf
aber dann erfährt er dass ein schiff in
der nähe in schwierigkeiten steckt
eugene kerle war als dritter offizier
der marine lag trick an bord
wir wurden gebeten umzukehren und die 4
dollar zu unterstützen
wäre sie gesunken hätten wir versucht
die besatzung zu retten
auf hoher see lässt man niemanden im
stich
der notruf erreicht die marien electric
auf ihren weg entlang der atlantikküste
sie transportiert 22.000 tonnen kohle
von norfolk in virginia bis nach sommers
in massachusetts
das 40 jahre alte schiff ist
sturmerprobt sie wurde während des
zweiten weltkriegs als tanker gebaut und
nach kriegsende zu einem frachter für
den kommerziellen schiffsverkehr
umgerüstet
die marien electric war oft in rauer see
gefahren alle waren sich sicher dass sie
mit dem unwetter zurechtkommen würde
auch die besatzung ist erfahren der
kapitän der marien electric fährt
bereits seit vier jahrzehnten zu sehen
fenster offiziers robert cue sieg er hat
die position der theodor registriert als
teamerin electric an ihr vorbeifuhr
sie war
ein sehr freundlicher vorgesetzter sehr
angenehm sagte mal alles erklärt und gab
sich nie von oben herab
er hatte salzwasser im blut er liebte
das meer schon als kleiner junge er war
15 als er anfängt zu fahren und 64 65
als er sich zur ruhe setzte
und zur vier toren zu kommen muss
kapitän colin sechs meter hohen wellen
eine 180 grad wende fahren
klarmachen zum kurswechsel klar
bei der wende steht die marine electric
kurz quer zu den wellen das timing muss
perfekt sein sonst kann das schiff
kentern
und wenn man sich selbst dabei in gefahr
bringt man muss anderen seeleuten in not
auf jeden fall helfen
jetzt 6 auf 220 roger ag auf 220
das finden das schiff wird von den heran
sondern den wellen durchgeschüttelt
michael war in der us handelsmarine
aktiv und weiß womit es die besatzung zu
tun hatte das ist als ob man auf der
autobahn beendet und der verkehr auf
einen zu recht sehr gefährlich
bei der wende erzitterte erst das
gesamte schiff
und als sie dann von der welle unterkam
verdrängte sie mit einem schlag
tonnenweise wasser
wendig wie ein ruderboot ketten die
wende gelingt perfekt
kohl machte das sehr gut er wusste was
er tat und hatte das schiff gut im griff
für offiziere und besatzung war klar
dass kein profi war
ich sehe licht zwei strich steuerbord
weisbrich steuerbar schnell finden sie
das schiff in seenot
sehen der 20 meter lange fischkutter hat
mit den sechs meter hohen wellen zu
kämpfen er läuft mit wasser voll und die
pumpen diaz abrunden sollen
funktionieren nicht
position 37 grad
50,1 minuten nord
74 grad
53,6 minuten west
der kapitän gibt die position an die
küstenwache durch und versucht der
theodora zu helfen
vielleicht können wir ihn schutz geben
er positioniert die riesige marin
electric so dass sie den putter gegen
den seegang so gut wie möglich abschirmt
bis die küstenwache eintrifft
so hatte die 4 dollar praktisch eine
wand aus stahl zwischen sich und den
großen wellen die sie bedroht
wir wurden ordentlich durchgeschüttelt
und die gespritzte über das deck aber
dann kam auch schon der helikopter der
küstenwache mit den entwässerungs
punkten und die wurden direkt
angeschlossen
theodora fast eine stunde lang ab
während das wasser abgepumpt wird
als der kutscher endlich außer gefahr
ist gibt die küstenwache der marien
electric grünes licht für die
weiterfahrt nach massachusetts
aber das unwetter wird immer schlimmer
der frachter kommt kaum voran
das war ein heftiger nordost sturm
durch jede welle schlägt sich das schiff
förmlichen durch in solchen stürmen kann
es passieren dass der ganze buch kurz
unter wasser ist
schiffe wie die marine electric sind so
konstruiert dass sie durch die welt
durchstoßen
das wasser überspült das deck und läuft
an den seiten wieder art
drehen bei
seiner fahrt voraus drehen bei kleine
fahrt voraus wir müssen es aussitzen
der kapitän verringert die
geschwindigkeit und dreht bei so steht
das schiff im sichersten winkel zu den
wellen
das unwetter ist eine ernste gefahr also
bleibt der kapitän auf der brücke auch
zum schlafen er wollte alle 15 minuten
geweckt und auf den neuesten stand
gebracht werden hatte er eine vorahnung
wer weiß
kennedy ich sehe gar nichts
[Musik]
der wind heute richtig er kam bestimmt
auf 65 70 kilometer pro stunde es war
wirklich übel
[Musik]
ich ging raus mal zu spüren wie heftig
das wetter war nur darum nicht um nach
anderen schiffen zu sehen oder eine
wetterprognose stellen zu können ich
wollte nur selbst spüren wie es draußen
war mir wurde schnell klar dass ich
besser nicht draußen bleiben sollte
überstunden ist im marien electric den
peitschenden regen und der schweren see
ausgesetzt
während sechs meter hohe wellen das
schiff durch schütteln bekommt kaum
jemand ein auge zu
ich mag einfach nur in der koje und
düste vielleicht mal fünf oder zehn
minuten
keine gemütlichen 8
dann wird der dritter offizier juden
kerli aufgeschreckt
so gegen 1 uhr klopfte jemand an meiner
tür
als sie spät merkte ich dass sich das
schiff anders verhielt
kelly täuscht sich nicht
küstenwache hier marin electric wir
sinken über buch
irgendetwas stimmt ganz und gar nicht
der bub kommt nicht mehr aus den willen
heraus
der vordere teil des chefs lag unter
wasser die wellen schlugen nicht mehr
aufs deck und liefen danach zu den
seiten ab als ich das sah wusste ich wir
sind in schwierigkeiten
[Applaus]
die marien electric liegt zu diesem
zeitpunkt rund 50 kilometer vor der
küste von virginia
der massengutfrachter hat im schweren
sturm immer mehr zu kämpfen
das wasser stand jetzt auf dem ganzen
weg
es sah fast aus wie ein wasserfall das
wasser brodelte überall
im februar ist das wasser des atlantiks
eisige vier grad kalt alle hoffen dass
sie nicht von bord gehen müssen
von bord zu gehen dass der letzte ausweg
das bedeutet dass man die probleme nicht
mehr in den griff kriegt und das schiff
verlassen muss was manchmal zunächst
noch schlimmer ist das wasser ist
eiskalt es ist tiefster winter der wind
heult und die wellen sind haushoch ein
rettungsboot ist keine verbesserung im
vergleich dazu auf dem schiff zu sein
kapitän kohl hat noch einen letzten
verzweifelten plan um den untergang zu
verhindern
ich versuche sie aufgrund sätzen klar
zum kurswechsel
die marien electric ist nur etwa 50
kilometer von der küste entfernt
gelingt es sie aufgrund zusetzen könnte
das schiff und besatzung lang genug über
wasser halten um von der küstenwache
gerettet zu werden
als ich hörte dass er richtung
nordwesten steuerte und das schiff auf
grund setzen wollte fand ich das schon
recht drastisch
sie steuern richtung land aber
inzwischen liegt der buch vollständig
unter wasser
das wasser schlug bis unten an stacks
haus und schäumte reizt
die luken deckel waren komplett
überspült und es gibt ein weiteres
problem
[Musik]
das wasser im schiff bringt es in
gefährliche schieflage
der frachter droht zu kentern
kapitän kraus setzt einen funkspruch ab
küstenwache wir sind in großen
schwierigkeiten
der stadt sind circa zwei stunden vor
ort
wir haben keine zwei stunden
[Musik]
küstenwache hier marin electric ich
glaube wir sinken
[Musik]
dann wurde es mir erst so richtig klar
als phil sagte wir senken
er brüllte nicht hysterisch bier sinken
oder so es war einfach eine feststellung
es muss sehr schwer gewesen sein aber
immer offenbar klar dass sie das so
nicht überleben würden da hat man dann
keine wahl mehr
schlagt
ihr geht von bord
[Musik]
die crew geht an deck
wenn man singt bleibt nur sehr wenig
zeit etwas zu unternehmen da wird einem
klar dass mutter natur einen einfach so
auslöschen kann
die männer versuchen ins rettungsboot zu
klettern was aber wegen der schlagseite
nicht geht
da hätte sich auch der grand canyon
auftun können es gab keine chance von
deck ins rettungsboot zu sprengen
der dritte offizielle youtube kerle weiß
das schiff könnte jeden moment kentern
und das rettungsboot mitreißen kelly für
einen stapel rettungsringe
und er fügt sie ins wasser wie ein
diskuswerfer
ich hatte frau und tochter da ein ich
hatte zwei hunde ein gutes leben und ich
wollte mich nicht von mir verschlucken
lassen
sekunden später beginnt der riesige
frachter zu kindern
pol do i beugte sich vor um das
rettungsboot näher heran zu ziehen und
dann viele einfach von bord
er war der erste der ins wasser stürzte
und während das schiff kippte hörte ich
leute schreien und brüllen
[Musik]
und dann kam mir das schon stein
entgegnen
in einem urschrei rief ich nach meiner
mutter
[Musik]
als die marien electric voll ins kentert
stürzt carey mit nichts als einer
rettungsweste und seiner kleidung am
leib ins eisige wasser
es war unbeschreiblich kalt als würde
man in einen schraubstock gezwängt der
immer enger wird
ich konnte nicht mehr atmen
um sich herum sieht er die anderen
besatzungsmitglieder
ich trieb dort in meiner rettungsweste
und strampelte wenn mich eine welle
empor trug konnte ich die leuchten all
der anderen westen sehen dann im
wellental sah ich wieder nur ein oder
zwei lichter
das aufgewühlte meer ist eiskalt wenn
nicht bald hilfe eintrifft wird niemand
überleben
du hast eine minute um deine atmung in
den griff zu bekommen dann bleiben zehn
minuten in denen du dich noch
kontrolliert bewegen kannst und eine
stunde bis du bewusstlos wird
während er in der dunkelheit vor sich
hin treibt hat kelly glück im unglück
ich stieß gegen etwas es waren fünf
andere männer die sich an einen
rettungsring klammerten
[Musik]
kerner hält sich ebenfalls daran fest
und gemeinsam kämpfen sie im eisigen
wasser ums überleben
es war quälend kalt die anderen am
rettungsring drifteten immer wieder in
den schlaf ab
[Musik]
robert staab ganz leise
er schlief ein und ich fragte richie
alles okay richie er antwortete nicht
unterkühlung ist ein furchtbarer tot
nach außen wirkt das vielleicht
friedlich und sehr verlockend einfach
einzuschlafen und vielleicht später
wieder aufzuwachen
kaum noch bei bewusstsein hört kelly
nach über einer stunde im wasser ein
geräuschen sich
es ist ein rettungshubschrauber der
us-küste rennen
es war als käme der engel der
barmherzigkeit zu uns herab ich griff
nach der taschenlampe und strahlte damit
in den himmel in der hoffnung dass es
jemand sieht
der helikopter ist mit einem
rettungskorb ausgerüstet um überlebende
zu bergen
allerdings aus rettungsbooten die
schiffbrüchigen besatzungsmitglieder
sind aber in wasser
sie sind so durchgefroren dass sie nicht
mehr selbstständig in den korb klettern
können
als nächstes trifft ein hubschrauber der
us navy ein und rettungsschwimmer james
mccann springt ins wasser er ist darauf
trainiert überlebende aus dem ozean zu
bergen ich schwimme zu der person hin
packe sie an der rettungsweste ohne
überhaupt zu gucken ob sie noch lebt und
schwimme rüber zum korb mccann ist der
einzige rettungsschwimmer vor ort nur er
kann die schiffbrüchigen direkt aus dem
wasser bergen
sie trieben zum teil mit dem gesicht
nach unten im wasser viele bewegten sich
überhaupt nicht mehr die arme hängen
herab und nur die beste hielt sie noch
an der oberfläche
fast eine stunde lang trotz mccann dem
eisigen wasser und birgt so viele
crewmitglieder wie er nur kann ich
merkte dass ich unterkühlte aber ich
wollte nicht aufhören dann sah der
teamleiter mich vom helikopter aus
zittern und holte mich raus
letzlich überleben nur drei
[Musik]
der erste offizier robert cue sieg und
der tritt offiziell gene kelly
[Musik]
warum habe ich überlebt
aber nun meine zeit war noch nicht
gekommen das sage ich den leuten immer
dass die marine electric gekentert ist
hat 31 menschen das leben gekostet aber
wie es dazu kommen konnte ist ein rätsel
die suche nach antworten sollte zu einer
der bedeutendsten
unfallermittlungen der amerikanischen
schifffahrt werden
die marien electric hat alles verändert
sieben stunden nachdem ihr gekentert ist
versinkt der massengutfrachter marin
electric frau christa virginias die
angehörigen der besatzung werden über
das unglück informiert
als ich von der marine electric hörte
war ich in meiner wohnung in höchst an
der universität von massachusetts
die tochter des
in der nacht fiel ein guter meter schnee
deswegen funktionieren die telefone
nicht
es klopft an der tür mein freund machte
auf da stand ein polizist er mir sagte
carroll ihr vater hat überlegt und ich
was überlebt und er sein chef ist
gesunken
ich war geschockt und bin meinem freund
nur noch schluchzend in die arme
gefallen
31 der 34
besatzungsmitglieder der marien electric
sind tot darunter auch kapitän philipp
crone
unter seefahrern bei der verlust der
männer von denen viele an unterkühlung
im kalten wasser gestorben waren ein
großes thema
im ring electric hatte fast 40 jahre
lang wind und wetter getrotzt warum ist
sie gekentert und auf dem grund des
atlantiks gesunden
mal sehen wo wir sind
in porz miss virginia beruf die us
küstenwache ein untersuchungsgremium 1
die leitung übernimmt kapitän peter
lorenz
die küstenwache ist für die untersuchung
tödliche unfälle auch sie zuständig es
wurden sofort ermittler eingesetzt die
informationen sammelten und an uns
weiterleiten
[Musik]
hallo schön sie zu sehen willkommen
aufgrund der schwere des unfalls
schließt sich die us
transportsicherheitsbehörde den
ermittlungen an
bei mehr als sechs toten musste
automatisch auch sie ermitteln
kommen wir zu den fraglichen punkten das
wetter scheint ein klarer faktor zu sein
aber lauritzen bezweifelt dass es die
alleinige ursache gewesen sein kann
das wetter hätte einen seetüchtigen
schiff keine probleme bereiten sollen
die ermittler nehmen alles unter die
lupe vom chef selbst bis zu möglichen
menschlichen versagen leuten ist auf
alle informationen angewiesen die er
bekommen kann wir brauchen das gutachten
die aktion und das ladungs verzeichnis
alles was du kriegst okay
taucher untersuchen das wrack und finden
den rumpf in mehrere große teile
zerbrochen am meeresgrund damit hat
lorenzen seine erste mögliche ursache
die fracht von gut 22.000 tonnen kohle
massengutfrachter müssen absolut korrekt
mit ihrer schweren ladung bestückt
werden sonst kann das gewicht das schiff
so stark belasten dass es zerbricht
[Musik]
belegt man die frachträume in der
falschen abfolge oder mit der falschen
menge kann es dazu führen dass das
schiff tatsächlich durchbricht
hat die crew womöglich an den tödlichen
fehler beim beladen gemacht bevor das
schiff auslief
die abfolge ist wichtig um das schiff
nicht zu überlasten okay ja danke war
[Musik]
sehen wir uns mal die beladung abfolge
und die lasten arinc
[Musik]
das team prüft die lage aufzeichnungen
findet aber keine anzeichen für fehler
nummer zwei die fracht war nicht zu
schwer und es wurde die korrekte abfolge
beim beladen eingehalten und das schiff
nicht zu überlasten
in dieser abfolge wurde das beladen
war ein normaler beladung prozess dass
wir vor der also nicht über die maßen
belastet
derweil geht die reederei marin
transport lions mit ihrer theorie zu den
ereignissen an die öffentlichkeit
innen gibt es die unterschiedlichsten
theorien jeder will seine interessen
schützen
wir kümmern uns darum wo haben sie
gesehen
ungefähr hier
die reederei geht davon aus dass der
frachter auf dem weg zur theodora ins
seichte wasser geriet und dabei der
rumpf beschädigt wurde
die theorie des eigners waren dass wir
auf unserem weg zur fiorenzo flaches
wasser gebieten und auf grund liefen
okay wir ein
um diese theorie zu überprüfen hört sich
die küstenwache an wie der kapitän
während des hilfseinsatzes war der
theodora die position der marien
electric durch gibt sie achten ganz
genau auf die angegebene position
position sieben und
[Musik]
prüfen sie dann auf der seekarte
53,6 minuten
[Musik]
nichts deutet darauf hin dass der
kapitän das schiff auf grund gesteuert
haben könnte
[Musik]
das bestätigen auch die überlebenden sie
hörten oder spürten nichts von einem
vermeintlichen kontakt zum grund
hört man dass im keller wenn jemand mit
einem hammer aufs dach haut aber jahr
hätten wir so etwas gehört hätten wir
doch noch löcher im rumpf oder einem
leck gesucht
es gibt zeugen ihre position stimmte sie
wussten wo sie waren sie sind nicht auf
grund gelaufen
die ermittler müssen eine andere
erklärung dafür finden warum die marien
electric kenterte und 31 menschen
sterben mussten
[Musik]
bei der untersuchung des untergangs
haben die ermittler nur wenige physische
beweismittel das schiff liegt auf dem
grund des atlantik
aber sie haben die funksprüche des
kapitäns an die us küstenwache
sie hoffen darin einen hinweis auf die
ursache des unglücks zu finden
küstenwache hier ist die marina electric
haben jetzt acht grad schlagseite
klar ist dass das schiff schnell an
stabilität und kurz vorm kentern stand
als der kapitän anweisung gab von bord
zu gehen
er stellte zur richtigen zeit fest dass
sie von bord gehen mussten er traf die
richtige entscheidung
noch mal abspielen
[Musik]
der bug ist geflutet
der kapitän sagte der küstenwache habe
wasser im buch
das würde erklären warum sich das schiff
nach vorne neigt wie es der dritte
offizielle gene kelly berichtet
ich war oft genug schiffen gewesen um zu
merken dass etwas nicht stimmte der bub
lag zu tief das war klar
aber warum war wasser in gut
nach dem untergang des us
massengutfrachter us-marine electric mit
31 toten kommt es zur anhörung vor einem
untersuchungskomitee
erklärt die reederei die besatzung habe
einen der riesigen fracht bluten deckel
vorne auf dem schiff nicht ordentlich
gesichert die deckel müssen wasserdicht
sein wasserdicht ist nicht dasselbe wie
wetterfest wasserdicht hält wasser auf
unter druck stand wetterfest nur regen
es ist eine grundlage der seefahrt wenn
eine lupen deckel nicht wasserdicht
verschlossen ist kann der frachtraum bei
schwerer see geflutet werden das könnte
auch den tief im wasser liegenden buchte
marin electric kurz von kindern erklären
aber einer der überlebenden der erste
offizier robert cue sieg war für die
beladung zuständig und er ist sicher die
crew hat nichts falsch gemacht
musik macht sich für seine aussage vor
dem untersuchungsgremium bereit er hat
seine eigene theorie zur unglücksursache
und will nicht dass die verstorbenen
kollegen beschuldigt werden sie
respektierten sich untereinander sehr
sie waren ein team viele von ihnen waren
schon lange auf dem schiff er sagte
immer sie sein wie brüder
aber es wird ihm nicht leicht gemacht
damals waren diese befragungen durch das
untersuchungsgremium sehr hart das war
kein angenehmes gespräch
der erste offizier berichtet von seinem
überlebenskampf nachdem er mit den
anderen von bord gegangen war
er tauchte entlang des rumpfes und sah
sogar das fenster seiner kajüte darin
brannte noch licht aber alles war unter
wasser er guckte hinein
[Musik]
dann kam er an die wasseroberfläche und
um sich herum sah er nichts
gerichtszeichner illustrieren was er
beschreibt
demming
[Musik]
es ist ein bewegender bericht aber das
ist erst der anfang musik hat eine
triftige erklärung für den untergang der
marine electric er war ein ehrlicher
ehrenhafter mensch und hätte niemals das
andenken an seine kollegen beschmutzt in
dem gegenüber das schiff erzählt
[Musik]
musik bestätigt den verdacht der
reederei dass die riesigen luppen deckel
nicht gesichert werden das sei
allerdings schuld der eigner nicht der
besatzung nicht alle deckel waren
hundertprozentig gesichert denn bei
einigen war das mechanisch nicht mehr
möglich
über jahre hinweg hatte kousek den
zunehmenden verfall des schiffs
dokumentiert jetzt informiert er das
gremium darüber er wusste dieses schiff
an nicht in ordnung und scheut er sich
nicht das zu sagen
ob kannte alle schwachstellen
er hatte eine liste von wartungsarbeiten
die wegen budgetkürzungen nicht
ausgeführt worden waren die luken decke
waren alt verbogen und gerissen sie
schlossen nicht mehr richtig und hätten
beim letzten werftaufenthalt repariert
werden sollen aber sie blieben in
schlechtem zustand
dort hatte zeichnungen davon gemacht die
er bei sich zu hause aufbewahrte
die aussage veranlasst das gremium die
unterlagen zur wartungshistorie des
schiffes genau unter die lupe zu nehmen
diese tragödie hätte nie geschehen
dürfen
unfassbar
aufzeichnungen waren sehr
aufschlussreich ist
zur reederei und sagst wir wollen alle
reparatur abrechnungen sehen alles was
genehmigt oder nicht genehmigt wurde
dann gleich zu die rechnung mit den
aussagen von zeugen und werftarbeitern
ab und geht dabei 23 jahre zurück bei
der elektrik mindestens drei jahre
den ruf allen mitteln gelingt ein
glückstreffer einer der lupen deckel des
schiffes wurde nur drei monate vor dem
unglück ausgetauscht
sie finden den alten deckel und
untersuchen sein zustand mit
alarmierenden ergebnis
dünn wie ein blatt papier und zu 75
prozent hinüber die halterungen waren
genau so marode
die reederei hatte in erster setzt als
er schon sehr viel musik hatte ausgesagt
bei reparaturen an den luken deckeln und
am deckt seien auf anweisung der eigner
minderwertige materialien eingesetzt
worden darunter auch ein epoxydharz
namens red hand es ist nicht dauerhaft
wasserfest und nicht ansatzweise so
stabil die stahl der ausgetauschte lupen
deckel stützt classics aussage
dass red hemd wurde benutzt um hunderte
risse am schiff aufzuführen auf dem deck
an den luken seiten selbst an den luken
deckeln einfach überall
wenn man auf die luken deckel trat lief
man gefahr durch zu krachen sie sollten
eigentlich tonnen von meerwasser
aushalten die löcher entdeckt wurden
farblich markiert damit niemand
stolperte
letztlich geht es doch immer um geld
schmeißen wir einfach eine platte über
das loch dann kanns weitergehen
wir kümmern uns drum wenn wir das
nächste mal im trockendock liegen
in den unterlagen der reederei stoßen
die ermittler auf noch eine extreme oder
abdeckung die trocken fragt luke
sie ist am bug der oft unter wasser war
während das schiff durch die hohen
wellen vor
küstenwache hier marin electric wir
scheinen vorne voll wasser zu laufen
das passt vorne am bug
es ist das fehlende puzzleteil
jetzt haben die ermittler ein klares
bild davon wie es zu dem unglück
gekommen ist
ich sehe rein gar nichts
der wassereinbruch begann schon
irgendwann am frühen abend
wählen die über den bug schlugen dran
durch die marode trocken fach luke und
löcher entdeckt
so kann was er dort hin wo es nicht
hätte sein sollen
das enorme gewicht des wassers zog den
bug nach unten und machte die lupen
deckel weiter hinten noch angreifbarer
für die wellen
auf die luken deckel stürzten tausende
tonnen wasser ein
die wellen drang durch die maroden
lobten deckel und fluteten die
frachträume
küstenwache wir sinken über burg
die luken deckel laden komplett unter
wasser
das geflutete schiff wurde immer
instabiler und bekam schließlich
schlagseite
als das geschah war es verloren
lohmann von dort los
hier geht von bord
jetzt wissen die ermittler dass die
marien electric ein schlecht zusammen
gepflegter seelenverkäufer war
trotzdem war sie im februar 1981 und im
juni 82 nur sieben monate vor dem
unglück durch die sicherheits inspektion
gekommen
30 minuten für die inspektion und
fassbar
in den unterlagen der us küstenwache und
des american chipping finden sich
erschreckende hinweise auf nachlässige
inspektion
shipping ist ein privatunternehmen das
den rumpf inspizieren und seine
sicherheit lösen sollte
jeder lücken decke jede wasserdichte
oder wetterfeste öffnung hätte geprüft
werden müssen
da war ein riss im tech der mit
sprühfarbe eingekreist worden war und
die inspektoren der küstenwache gingen
kommentarlos darüber hinweg
die unfallermittler werfen sowohl dem
american way of shipping als auch der us
küstenwache vor dass sie die
offensichtlichen schäden beverin
electric nicht erkannt oder sie
ignoriert hätten
tatsächlich wurden die eindeutig
verrotteten luken deckel des 40 jahre
alten vaters bei der letzten inspektion
nicht einmal darauf getestet ob sie
regen dicht waren normalerweise wird das
mit einem wasserschlauch gemacht
[Musik]
bei einem so alten schiff mit lupen
deckeln in diesem zustand keinen
schlauch test in der werft zu machen ist
mindestens fahrlässig
[Musik]
unfassbar
die unfallermittler müssen feststellen
dass die inspektoren klare anzeichen
mangelnder wartung übersehen haben es
ist unglaublich dass ein so altes schiff
in diesem zustand nicht so genau geprüft
wurde wie es der fall hätte sein müssen
ein problem bei allen regulierungen ist
dass die standards langsam absenken
können das american bureau of shipping
und die küstenwache waren schluderig
geworden
aber die unfallermittler untersuchung
nicht nur warum die marine electric
kenterte sondern auch warum die
us-küstenwache nicht mehr als drei der
vier und 30 besatzungsmitglieder retten
konnte
ein helikopter der küstenwache traf als
erster vor ort ein war aber nur
unzureichend ausgerüstet
um menschen aus notsituationen zu retten
verfügte die crew der küstenwache zu
dieser zeit über einen großen helikopter
der bei ruhiger see auch im meer landen
konnte und einen rettungskorb aber die
aufgewühlte see machte eine wasserung
des helikopters unmöglich und durch die
eisige kälte waren die meisten
überlebenden kaum noch bewegungsfähig
bei der elektrik wurde der rettungskorb
zu menschen herab gelassen die nicht
hineinklettern konnten die helikopter
crew konnte nur treibstoff verbrennen
und zu sehen wie die schiffbrüchigen
erfroren erst volle 45 minuten später
traf ein nato helikopter mit einem
rettungsschwimmer an bord ein
baby hatte rettungsschwimmer um
abgestürzten piloten retten zu können
jetzt retteten sie zivile seeleute also
ordnete der us kongress an dass die
küstenwache ein rettungsschwimmer
programm ins leben ruft um hilflose
personen aus dem wasser bergen zu können
1984 im jahr nach dem unglück eröffnete
die us-küstenwache ihre
rettungsschwimmer schule in elisabeth
city north carolina
heute müssen sich alle sehr rettungs
trainingsprogramme an diesem standard
messen lassen
in der einrichtung kann man realistische
und wetterbedingungen mit blitzen und
hohen wellen nachstellen so wird die
fähigkeit der schwimmer geprüft und
rettungs situation ruhig und
konzentriert zu bleiben petty officer
james l ist einer der ausbilder die
trainings einrichtung ist fantastisch
hier können sie lernen die situation
richtig einzuschätzen auch die details
zu achten und alleine im einsatz zu sein
denn sobald du aus dem helikopter raus
bist liebt es alleine an dir jede runde
deutliche ansagen verstanden
die ausbildung hat es in sich sowohl
physisch als auch mental von den rund 75
anwärtern wie jedes jahr hier anfangen
schafft es durchschnittlich nicht einmal
die hälfte bis zum ende
die jungen leute die wir hier ausbilden
sind wie ein schweizer messer sie
trainieren doppelt so hart wie ich
damals das sind profi leistungssportler
laut schätzung der us küstenwache haben
ihre rettungsschwimmer bis 2017 über
21.000 leben gerettet
das motto ist auf das andere leben nicht
auf dass ich heil nach hause kommen ich
springe ins wasser und wolle die leute
daraus oder ich gehe dabei drauf
der abschlussbericht der us küstenwache
über den untergang der marien electric
bringt auch in der seefahrt neuerungen
von 1984 an müssen schiffe wie die
marina electric in kalten gewässern
überlebens anzüge für alle an bord
bereitstellen ein solcher anzug kann das
einsetzen der unterkühlung bis zu sechs
stunden lang hinauszögern
kurse über das überleben bin mir gegeben
immer wenn wir zu den überlebens anzügen
kamen sagte ich erzähle euch jetzt eine
geschichte über die marien electric und
die seeleute die damals starben
dabei werde ich immer emotional haben
ihr habt glück dass wir heute diese ein
ziel gehabt denn die männer damals sind
gestorben sie hatten keine
die empfehlung der unfallermittler
führen auch zu strengeren inspektions
vorschriften und mehr kontrollen
die marien electric war ein alter
massengutfrachter dessen wartung
vernachlässigt wurde vor allem von lupen
deckeln und hauptdeck
[Musik]
nach außen hin behauptete das
unternehmen sicherheit stünde an erster
stelle aber das entsprach nicht den
tatsachen
löcher in den luken deckeln und im rumpf
wurden einfach ignoriert nur noch eine
fahrt dann gibt es ein neues schiff
aber dann gab es immer noch eine farbe
die reederei hat versagt die küsten
versagt
hat versagt diese menschen waren
verantwortlich und cue sie lieferte uns
die beweise
nach genaueren kontrollen wurden
anschließend mehr als 90 alte weltkriegs
frachter außer dienst gestellt
robert kotick verstarb 2013 die
radikalen änderungen halfen ihm
zumindest ein bisschen bei der
verarbeitung des unglücks
ich habe mich oft gefragt wie viele
leben meinem vater wohl gerettet hat
oder zumindest dazu beigetragen hat dass
dank seiner aussage so viele schiffe aus
dem verkehr gezogen wurden hat ihm
sicher dabei geholfen mit seinen
schuldgefühlen als überlebender
umzugehen
[Musik]
der untergang der marien electric hat
eine der umfassendsten reformen in der
geschichte der us schiff nach sich
gezogen
wir ehren die 31 die gestorben sind wir
konnten das unglück nicht verhindern
aber wir haben dafür gesorgt dass ihr
tod nicht umsonst war